الرواية
[موسيقى]
إنها حقًا استخدام رائع
للتكنولوجيا لأن هذا
الإحساس سيساعد المستهلكين
على التوصية بالعطر المناسب
لهم استنادًا إلى قياس
مشاعرهم عندما يشمون أوتارًا مختلفة
من العطر
[الموسيقى]
فهو يقيس المشاعر  لديك
استبيان ويقيس العواطف
عندما تشم رائحة مختلفة من العطور
ويخبرك بما يجعلك
سعيدًا متوتراً
واثقًا من
وجود معايير مختلفة
وترى المنحنيات التي يتم قياسها
في الوقت الذي تشم فيه هذه السيدة
الرائحة الآن والآلة  يقيس
ما هذا على
أنه عواطف
[موسيقى]
ما زلنا نسمع الكثير عن
التخصيص والتخصيص
ليس فقط
إنشاء منتج تم تصميمه لقياسه ، بل
يساعد أيضًا المستهلكين في العثور على
المنتجات المناسبة لهم من بين
آلاف المنتجات الموجودة في
السوق  إنه جزء من مستقبل
التسوق
[الموسيقى
] وأنا متأكد من أننا سنجده في غضون سنوات قليلة
حتى أنك تعرف
طرقًا أبسط وأسرع للقيام بذلك ، لكن في الوقت
الحالي أعتقد أنه من أحدث التقنيات إلى حد كبير
، وإذا كان المستهلكون
سعداء به ، فنحن سعداء به